more the police stole told to stand down
did the police tell emergency responders
to stand down and we're gonna take a
look at the government's record on
mental health because all of this is
relevant to the big gun control debate
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show so first off i just want to thank
all the folks who showed up last night
at university of minnesota we had a
packed house about 500 people showed up
to to pack a pretty crowded room there
were 100 police officers who show up for
about maybe 40 protestors at most the
protesters were not violent nothing
really happened but they had a full
squat gear people racking their m4 so
this is how insane it's become on
America's college campuses when that
sort of stuff is necessary I'll have a
few more notes on that a little bit
later and a lot of news to get to here
today including some more information
updates on what happened in parkland
that story just gets worse and worse but
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at helix sleep so I'm on
the road does it look like I've been
sleeping well I haven't the reason is
because I'm not on my helix sleep
mattress helix sleep makes the best
mattresses there are on the market for a
couples they'll even purchase analyze
each side of the mattress here's how it
works you go to helix sleep calm slash
bed you take their simple two to three
minutes sleep quiz and they will build
you a custom mattress they'll be the
best thing you have ever slept on and
when you're away from home you're gonna
miss your helix sleep mattress every
single time everybody is recommending
helix sleep and there's a reason that
custom mattress arrives to your door in
a week shipping is completely free and
then you can try it for a hundred nights
so if you don't love it they will pick
it up and they will refund you info I
don't know anybody personally that this
head that has actually done this because
that's how good the helix sleep mattress
is again it's a lot less expensive than
the stuff that you would get store
bought and it's better quality as well
they have this algorithm asks you do you
like to prefer on it to sleep on your
back or on your side or on your stomach
do you prefer the mattress to be firm or
soft and then they personalize it to
your comfort helix sleep comm / Ben
right now use the slash pending at $50
toward your custom mattress that's helix
sleep comm / Ben again 50 bucks off
toward your order that's helix sleep
comm slash men checked that out they
also have a bunch of additional products
like they've the helix mattress
protector machine washable dryer safe
completely waterproof they've the helix
foundation which is seven and a half
inches of solid pine upholstered with
the same woven fabric as your helix
mattress so all sorts of good stuff over
at helix sleep comm / Ben again you get
50 bucks toward your custom mattress
when you go to helix sleep
/ better okay so time for some updates
on what has happened in parkland so
every day there's more information now
coming out on what the sheriff's office
in Broward County did and did not do in
the lead-up to during the attack and in
the aftermath of the of the parkland
shooting attack at the school shooting
and it is really astonishing me the more
information that comes out the worse
this get so according to Miami Herald
today the shooter threatened classmates
posted photos of himself holding guns
made violent statements online and there
was repeatedly described to authorities
as a potential school shooter his
troubling behavior gave law enforcement
plenty of opportunities to investigate
and arrest him according to Miami Herald
and even take away his guns long before
he shot up Marjorie Stoneman Douglas
High School in parkland last week
according to interviews with former
Florida South of South Florida
prosecutors and legal experts now
remember sheriff Scott Israel had
claimed that there was no way under law
from they actually confiscate the
weapons of the shooter or to arrest the
shooter that is not true according to
miami-dade a prosecutor Marshall Doreen
Lewis says quote there's no doubt that
was a failure and the idea that they
were aware of it and could do nothing is
absurd we can't let this happen again so
not only did the FBI refused to act on
too strong tips one of which involved
the shooter posting on the internet that
he plan to become a professional school
shooter which is illegal that's a
terrorist threat the Palm Beach
Sheriff's Office was told the shooter
had put a gun to other's heads in the
past the Florida Department of Children
and Families ruled him stable despite
clear evidence of self harm and at the
school where the where the shooter
killed 17 people they knew he was
cutting himself threatening students and
taking pictures with guns and that he
may have ingested gasoline in an attempt
to commit suicide and nothing was done
about any of these things they did have
the legal authority to go in and arrest
him they had the legal authority to
ensure that he did not have weapons they
did not do any of those things they
dropped the ball they really blew it now
there are some rumors out there and
we'll see if they're substantiated Sarah
Rumph / red state has a long piece about
it it is obvious that the the Sheriff's
of Broward County have been attempting
to minimize the number of arrests that
take place on campus the reports that
the student that the shooter was
expelled from the school are not true he
was actually allowed to remain in the
school and there are a lot of questions
being asked today about whether the
determination to end the so-called
school to Prison Pipeline allowed the
police to let this guy off the hook that
basically they didn't want to be part of
that school
Prison Pipeline so instead they let an
incipient school shooter run around on
the loose with guns which would just be
devastating we'll see if there's more
information that comes out about that
even if the case couldn't have been made
the arrests should have happened the
teen might have been placed squarely on
the radar of police analysts and then
anytime anything else came up there
would be more action taken by the police
one another prosecutor named pre Ovilus
according Miami Herald says at the very
least the most capable intelligence
detectives should have been monitoring
him the sheriff has said that the BSO's
handling of tips is under internal
investigation he says I don't know that
the signs were missed he said this isn't
science fiction were not allowed to
arrest on what a person thinks about on
pre crimes but this wasn't a matter of
pre crimes there are reports of this
shooter threatening other students that
is cyber stalking under the law in the
state of Florida there's pictures of the
student online brandishing guns and
talking about being a school shooter
these are crimes in the state of Florida
and there have been other people who
have been arrested for similar stuff
miami-dade schools policed on Friday
arrested Cropp High senior Shawn Mesa
for posting photos of himself with guns
on social media improper display of a
firearm is a misdemeanor in Florida
that's not the only case that is like
that there's another arrest that was
made in 2016 of somebody who is involved
in very similar behavior there is a
there is a Miami Dade police homeland
security bureau arrest of a guy named
Enrico coming.and Dominguez who is
posting apparently disturbing images of
himself dressed like the Joker with
combat style knives and his co-workers
report he pledged allegiance to al I
showed them Isis execution videos in
vowed to dress like the Joker
before gunning down co-workers they went
and arrested him why couldn't that have
applied here the answer is it could have
applied here but something happened at
the sheriff's office and they didn't do
their job and now we're finding out that
the the sheriff's office itself may have
told police officers to stand down so
Laura Ingraham reported on her show
yesterday that deputies were told to
stand outside and wait because they
didn't have body cameras on so because
there are no body cameras on the
detectives or on the on the sheriff's
deputies and because they didn't want to
go in without those body cameras so that
they could defend themselves against
possible lawsuit maybe whatever the case
was according to Ingram her sources in
the department say these deputies were
told to stand around outside while kids
were getting shot inside our
horses near the Broward County Sheriff's
Department are telling us that the
deputies who arrived at the scene of the
shooting were told not to enter the
school unless their body cameras were
turned on and then we found out that the
deputies did not have body cameras so
they did not enter or enter the building
or engage the shooter so curiously
police also lost radio communications
during the parkland shooting I mean this
is a massive botch they didn't even have
body cameras but they suddenly obeyed
the rule that they weren't allowed to go
into dangerous areas with body cameras
something is really fishy here there's
an EMT who's on national TV last night
an emergency medical respondent who is
saying that the police were barring them
from getting in they said they could
have saved some more lives if they've
been allowed to get in there right away
but they weren't allowed to get in there
the police were stopping them from going
in three high-ranking Florida officials
are expressing their frustration because
they say EMS was delayed getting inside
Stoneman Douglas High School on the day
of the shooting in the critical moments
when victims lay inside in need of
immediate care one source tells FOX News
some EMS teams requested to go inside
but were denied by the commanding agency
the Broward County Sheriff's Office that
source alleges scanner recordings will
reveal that okay this is amazing stuff
is amazing stuff and people are come
with the NRA and law abiding gun owners
as the problem we also now have a
response from the Broward deputy the the
Broward deputy Scott Peterson who's been
ripped up in town by the sheriff and
there's something fishy about the
sheriff ripping this this deputy up and
down and suggesting that he was a coward
there's something very fishy about a
sheriff who does not defend his cops and
who throws his cops under the bus now
may may be very well at this deputy
chicken down that's quite possible
that's not what he's saying according to
his lawyer quote allegations that mr.
Peterson was a coward and that his
performance under the circumstances
failed to meet the standards of police
officers are patently untrue let there
be no mistake mr. Peterson wishes he
could have prevented the untimely
passing of the 17 victims on that day
his heart goes out to the family of the
victims in their time of need
however the allegations that mr.
Peterson was a coward and that his
performance under the circumstances
failed to meet the standards of police
officers are patently untrue mr.
Peterson is confident that his actions
on that they were appropriate under the
circumstances and that the video
together with the eyewitness tests
those on the scene will exonerate him of
any subpar performance so this is
another one of the questions why don't
we have the video why don't we know what
happened they have video of what
happened there they have cameras on the
premises
this particular deputy was awarded the
school deputy of the Year in 2014
apparently according to Miami Herald he
was in another building dealing with a
student issue and the shot sounded he
was armed with his sidearm he ran to the
west side of building 12 and set up in a
defensive position then did nothing for
four minutes until the gunfire stopped
according to the sheriff but according
to this deputy he says that he heard the
gunshots but believed the gunshots were
originating from outside the building on
the school campus and he said BSO trains
its officers that in the event of a
outdoor gunfire want us to seek cover
and assess the situation in order to
communicate what one observes with other
law enforcement so maybe a mistake was
just made as opposed to cowardice or as
possible that there was something else
going on because we still have not fully
rebutted that CNN report that says it
was not one deputy on premises but four
deputies on premises who are outside
doing nothing and if Ingram's report is
correct if Flores report is correct then
that means that there were four people
outside who were told not to go in
because their body cameras weren't on
them which is just insane now meanwhile
the sheriff Scott Israel is doing his
best to avoid all culpability again
according to Laura Ingraham just a few
hours ago the Ingraham angle receives
copies of internal emails from a source
close to the Broward Sheriff's Office
which has since been confirmed by a
second source that email urges all staff
members to vigorously support sheriff
Israel so in other words he's too busy
defending his own ass to actually take
responsibility for what went on in his
department there's no question this
guy's a political actor through and
through Israel actually got into hot
water back in December why because
they're a bunch of Broward County
Sheriff's cars and he wrapped his he put
a wrap on the cars with his face on it
for political purposes they were
jokingly called Israel Mobile's by
members of the department and we
obviously know the sheriff loves
grandstanding we know he loves his
camera time he's never run from a camera
at any point and he apparently and he
knows full well what happened here we're
just not getting all the information now
there will be a full investigation that
takes place I'm sure that we will find
out what happened here I have a very
little doubt that it's going to cast
even more aspersions toward his behavior
in this whole thing it's truly
disastrous and truly frightening and
again the bottom line is this if you
expect me to give up my weapon when the
authorities won't even do their job you
must be out of your mind
if you think that I'm gonna give up my
method for defending myself because the
authorities want me to and then they
won't even defend my kids if my kids are
going to a school that they are assigned
try again not going to happen
there's only we know who blew it here
okay wasn't the NRA that blew it here it
was the FBI it was the local law
enforcement the reason this matters is
because we keep hearing about how we
need more laws on the books
well more laws on the books aren't going
to do anything if we're not enforcing
the laws that are already on the books
more laws aren't gonna change anything
if we're not actually changing things
which we're not of course so that means
that more of these school shootings are
likely to happen and the grandstanding
doesn't help either which brings us to
the grandstanding itself so there's been
a ton of focus on the on a specific
subset I should say of kids who were at
the Parkland school at Marjory Stoneman
High School when this happened and it's
a very specific subset and you know all
their names right you know Cameron
caskey you've seen him on TV and you
know Emma Emma Gonzalez you've seen her
on TV as well and she has now over a
million Twitter followers after having
basically zero Twitter followers a week
ago because the media have really been
pushing her out there and of course
David hog who's been on every TV show
that he can possibly find now they have
every right to speak as much as they
want and we have every right to
criticize them as much as we want
because this is still the United States
of America and just because you went
through something tough does not mean
that you're an expert on what happened
or why it happened it just means that
you're an expert on suffering as I've
said here on the show a bunch of times
hey but nonetheless we are being treated
to the awkward spectacle of these kids
being trotted out there by a compliant
media that actually has Charlie cook
over at over at National Review says are
laundering their views through the moral
bank accounts of these students all the
people in the media wish they could call
for a ban for guns every day on the air
they can't so instead they bring on
these kids to do it for them that's the
whole goal of having these kids as
guests and the kids are saying things
that are just insipid David hog
particularly has is a very bad spokesman
for his for his point of view not just
because he's a good-looking kid who can
complete a sentence doesn't mean
anything he says makes any sense and
again this is not a rip on him as a
victim and this is a rip on him as
political commentator you either say
things that are intelligence or you
don't and your experiences have nothing
to do with it this is a form of identity
politics in the same way that the left
will maintain that your opinion should
be
not based on the actual content or value
of your opinion but based on the color
of your skin your ethnicity your
religion your background instead of
Abdullah instead of doing it on that
basis they're saying that we should now
judge the the decency of your viewpoint
or the genius of your viewpoint based
solely on whether you went through a
terrible experience at a school shooting
so here is David hog suggesting once
again for the umpteenth time the
politicians don't care about kidlat
kids lives he cares deeply about kids
lives David hog he cares so deeply that
he's called for a boycott of Amazon he's
held for a boycott in the state of
Florida because there's nothing like
harming those family business owners
down in Miami Beach you have to make
sure that those new immigrants can't
sell their tacos during spring break we
got to make sure that doesn't happen so
he wants people to boycott Florida until
the gun laws in Florida change he has
spoken at a rally in New Jersey he is
pushing for a boycott against FedEx he
says he's not gonna go back to school
until he gets what he wants well tough I
mean then they don't go back to school
that's that's not true anyway he will be
back at school in any case he was doing
this routine again yesterday politicians
don't care about kids lives this is the
worst form of demagoguery and here he is
saying it these politicians don't care
about these children's lives
notice how the only action being taken
for example with Rick Scott is after he
is running for Senate to try to take
Bill dose and seat that's what's going
on here people need to acknowledge that
and like with Marco Rubio for example
the man must be a professional dancer
just like other politicians because he's
great at sidestepping questions at the
CNN Town Hall he turned a 1-1 word
answer into a five sentence shenanigan
emitting propaganda from the NRA and
repeating his false message that he's
got his message that he's going to
continue to accept money from the NRA
just making sure that people don't
understand that and they're distracted
by him trying to turn it into a long
answer so he can get reelected and it's
this guy he didn't obstruct at all he
said he would continue to take money
from the NRA because he's a proponents
of second Amendment rights I mean
senator Rubio was perfectly honest on
that special about whether he would take
money from the NRA again when David Hawk
says all of these very very silly things
when he suggests that it's about the
Governor Rick Scott or it's about the
Senator Marco Rubio bill Nelson has
nothing to do with it right bill Nelson
has all the right views that's totally
fine this is the same guy David hog who
went on TV and defended Scott Israel the
actual Sheriff of Broward County right
the guy who's botched everything the
entire first part of the show is about
all of the battery by the sheriff's
office and yet somehow Rick Scott is
responsible for the deputy not doing his
job but the Sheriff's Office is not
responsible for the deputy doing his job
pretty astonishing stuff pretty
astonishing stuff okay so David hog goes
out there and he says this sort of
nonsense and then of course he is feeded
by the media for it so Jimmy Fallon does
the same thing here's Jimmy Fallon
praising the Parkland students and
suggesting that they are all heroes and
he's going to march with them so it's
not enough by the way that we have one
Pope of politics in Jimmy Kimmel on
late-night now we have to have two popes
of politics on late-night Jimmy Fallon
joins Jimmy Kimmel in this effort
Stephen Colbert of course has been the
Pope of politics before so we actually
have the Holy Roman Empire and the
kingship is passed around the Emperor
ship is passed around between various
parties depending on how the ratings are
fallon wants to get in the game because
he's been ripped as to anodyne as to
lackluster as not political enough by a
lot of left-wing commentators and
therefore he wants to get in the game so
here is Jimmy Fallon doing his best
Jimmy Kimmel impression he needs to grow
a little bit of stubble and cry if he
really wants to do this right I think
what the students of Marjory Stoneman
Douglas High School are doing is
unbelievable they're speaking out with
more guts passion conviction and common
sense and most adults their high school
students it's beyond impressive that
strength that they have it's inspiring
they are angry and they're doing
something about it and creating change
this is a real revolution and they have
organized a peaceful march on Saturday
March 24th in Washington DC to demand
action to prevent gun violence I just
want to say I stand behind you guys and
I will be marching alongside you with my
wife and two children in DC to show our
support
Wow how nice I mean it's all the late
night house immediately coming out and
signaling virtue signaling that
everything that these kids have to say
is wonderful the bravery the decency
okay they're not going to talk to you
know some of the other students they're
not going to talk to you know some of
the some of the people who I've
recommended that they talk to I'm sure
they're not gonna talk to Kyle Kashyap
who still was unverified on Twitter by
the way I thank you for following him
he's one of the students there who
disagrees with with some of these other
students but he of course is not
appearing every single day you don't
know his name because he's not on CNN or
MSNBC every single day as still as I say
unverified on Twitter no
back there but again this is what the
entire Hollywood infrastructure is gonna
do the Oscars will be about that on
Sunday night you watch they they were
gonna do me too
but now this obviously allows them to
virtue signal on another topic now never
mind that half the people in the
audience have done movies in which guns
are glorified is the way of stopping
violence never mind that all those
people are millionaires who are
protected by armed security outside you
watch on Sunday during the Oscars the
entire thing will be about how we need
to get rid of guns in our society and
then presumably all of our action movies
can be Bruce Lee's style karate fights
that's that's basically what what all of
these things will turn into so there's a
problem with with the suggestion that
the children shall lead us and that the
kids shall lead us it's it's a different
problem even than the identity politics
question of does victimhood confer
expertise and that is a lot of kids are
not all that bright I mean not and I'm
not saying these kids who are or
speaking on TV are bright you know for
their age I'm sure they're very bright
I'm talking about are these kids yeah
our kids in general capable of the kind
of decision-making that adults are
capable of and the answer as a general
rule is no which is why of course we
have legal restrictions on kids buying
cigarettes and kids buying alcohol and
kids buying guns and all the rest of
this sort of thing there's a reason that
16 year-olds don't vote now there's a
lot of people have gotten on my case for
saying this because I was writing
syndicated columns at 17 well that's
fine you know I was taking flak at 17 -
and there are people saying I was too
young to write columns then and some of
the stuff I wrote I think was dumb I
think if I look back at the stuff that I
wrote when I was 17 I think a lot of
it's good I think some of it's not so
good and I hope that I've matured over a
period of time people generally do but
that's sort of the point when you can
when you grant this this pure virtue to
children to be our political leaders it
doesn't end well so I'm going to show
you some video of it not ending well so
over in Bakersfield yesterday there was
a student protest over guns now why
there should be a student protest over
guns in Bakersfield in the state with
the most gun restrictions in America or
at California where I live has
incredible gun restrictions there's a
protest over in Bakersfield and the kids
of course use this as an excuse to leave
school and basically run roughshod
through the community because let's face
it most of the kids who are getting
involved in this cause are not doing so
because they want the extra credit in
class or because they deeply care about
the issue or know anything about the
issue they're doing it because it's fun
just like most protesters do things
because they are
okay so here are some video of the kids
and notice how the adults essentially
let them have their way because after
all kids are our moral leaders now this
is clip sixteen hundreds of students
took to the streets to protest gun
violence
these students from Stagg high school
were told by officers to disperse the
streets the Stockton School District
says what started out as a peaceful
protest on campus turned rowdy as about
100 of 300 students jumped the fence of
the school some were seen throwing rocks
at cars including police cars like I go
to Delta College so okay yeah those are
the kids who are to lead us those are
the kids who ought to lead us no not
every kid is these kids obviously but
you suggest that children are the wisest
among us yeah no they're not okay I have
two kids
I remember being as young as these kids
when you're 1415 years old you don't
have a lot of and there's not a lot
going on upstairs that prevents you from
doing stupid things is in Stockton not
Bakersfield obviously but when you grant
absolute moral immunity to kids because
they are young you end up with worse
kids one of the worst things that you
can do as a parent is suggest to your
children that they have the absolute
moral immunity to do whatever they want
parenting is about teaching and
cultivating children it is not about
granting children leadership positions
and suggesting that in the absence of
knowledge they are leaders because after
all they're so innocent and the innocent
children among us Shelly I think that's
just absolutely silly now these kids and
their impact is they they wouldn't be
making this sort of it would they
wouldn't be as big a phenomenon as they
become except that the media have
obviously magnified their influence to
tremendous tremendous effect and the
media are even worse at this stuff than
a lot of the child advocates are they're
members of the media who legitimately
know nothing about what they're talking
about so we're gonna show you some some
members of the media saying things about
guns that are utterly asinine and then
they're supposed to we're supposed to
leave their experts we're supposed to
believe that these people know what
they're talking about and really really
astonishing so here's Stephanie ruhle on
MSNBC making one of the worst arguments
in history for why we ought to ban
rifles an ar-15 style rifle well that's
a semi-automatic weapon meaning the fire
fires one round when the trigger is
pulled then automatically reloads the
chamber making it ready to fire again
handguns can also be semi-automatic but
some like revolvers they're not meaning
it can take a lot longer to fire
multiple rounds another big difference
the speed of bullets the ar-15 can fire
bullets between 2,800 and 3,000 feet per
second a 9-millimeter handgun between
700 and 1100 feet per second so I'm
really enjoying the media doing this
routine about the speed of bullets as
though that is the only thing that
matters in terms of the amount of damage
that is done the caliber of the bullet
matters also right the size of the
actual bullet matters beyond that if
we're going to talk about guns that are
used in the killings of human beings
there's no question that rifles are the
vast minority of guns that are used in
the killing of other human beings in the
United States like 13% of all murders
involving guns involve rifles 60%
involve handguns and then the rest
involve weapons that have not really
been specified
the notion again that we're going to
measure the velocity of the bullets and
that therefore we ought to ban rifles
but not ban handguns it's just silly and
again if you're gonna make the argument
that lawrence O'Donnell made the other
night that a person with a handgun can't
stop somebody with an ar-15 that's again
ridiculous considering that in the
Congressional baseball shooting the guy
apparently had an ar-15 and it was a
person with a handgun who took him down
this happens fairly regularly hey but
it's not just Stephanie ruhle making a
fool of herself and this this one was
making rounds yesterday local NBC trying
to destroy what the firing of they are
looks like and how much damage you can
do yeah there's only one problem with
that particular video that is definitely
not an ar-15 right there that is a
shotgun that is a pump-action shotgun
it's not even a semiautomatic shotgun
it's a pump-action shotgun meaning that
you have to manually chamber the round
so well-done media yes I'm definitely
gonna trust you on what types of guns
ought to be banned when you literally
cannot tell the difference between a
semi-automatic and automatic and a
manual revolver for example when you
can't tell the you can't explain to me
why it is that velocity of a handgun
matters as opposed to velocity of a
rifle all of this is John
ridiculous and then of course you have
the the people grandstanding off the
back of this who again know nothing
about guns Whoopi Goldberg yesterday on
the view suggesting that the GOP is
silent about guns because the GOP is
corrupt but does Whoopi Goldberg know
the first thing about guns or how many
of these gun laws would affect anybody
they should know how many ar-15s are in
circulation the answer is at least eight
million in the United States does you
know how many rifles are in circulation
in the United States tens of millions
does she know the answer to how many
guns are in circulation in the United
States or where the crime rates are
highest or which states have the highest
rates of gun violence or how many of the
killings with guns are actually suicides
the answer is 2/3 right does Whoopi
Goldberg know any of that no she just
knows that guns are bad and so she's
gonna rip on the GOP for being silent
about guns she makes I think the dumbest
point of the day yesterday on the view
the repository of many dumb points here
she is you know one that when the
athletes were kneeling every Republican
sort of had something to say and many
have been wondering where they've been
where they stand on this particular
issue
okay and the answer is that all of the
Republicans sounded off on players
kneeling because they thought players
kneeling was wrong
they haven't sounds it off about
law-abiding citizens owning guns because
they don't think law-abiding citizens
owning guns is wrong or bad this is not
difficult there's an actual political
reason an actual values reason why so
many conservatives are not speaking up
about why guns should be confiscated
because we don't think guns should be
confiscated or the sale of them should
be man and again it's amazing to me I've
proposed on this on this program at
least three different measures that we
can all take as a society in order to in
order to push forward against the
scourge of mass shootings and none of
these have been seriously discussed by
the media they would prefer to just
shout guns guns guns ban ban ban
confiscate confiscate confiscate but
none of them actually want to talk about
serious hard proposals the Democrats
apparently have now made a move in the
house they've introduced a piece of
legislation to ban all semi-automatic
rifles of course this is going nowhere
and they know it the reason they're
proposing it is because they want kudos
from a bunch of the people on in the
media they want to campaign on it as
I've said before the Democrats had
control of Congress they had full
control of the Senate meaning 60 votes
in the Senate they had controlled the
house they had controlled the presidency
from 2009 to 2011 did they pass one
single gun reg regulation the answer of
course is no they waited until
Republicans to
and now they get to grandstand they get
to stand there and claim there's
Republicans who are standing between
Americans and safety if those dastardly
Republicans would just get out of the
way then we'd be able to pass some
really good regulations they have no
intention of pushing anything remotely
resembling a good regulation they just
want to posture about all of this and
fortunately they have the media to do it
for them they've the media to stand
there and do it for them now there are
some folks who are actually mentioning
some solutions
you know those folks actually include
the presidents of the United States
so presidents of the United States has
actually put forward a couple of
different proposals I think some of
those proposals are smart I think some
of those proposals are not so smart now
one of the proposals they put out
yesterday was actually you know in good
in our good Trump bad front matrix this
goes in good Trump Trump talked about
mental institutions in the FATA and the
reality that we need to make it more
difficult for people who are a danger to
themselves and others not only to get
guns but also we need to make it easier
for them to get treatment here's Trump
talking about the history of mental
institutions in the country he got a lot
of flack for this yesterday but he's
absolutely correct this is clip number
five you know the old days we had mental
institutions in a lot of them and you
could nab somebody like this because you
know they did they knew he was something
resolved you had to know that people
were calling all over the place you
can't arrest him I guess cuz he hasn't
done anything but you know he's like a
boiler ready to explode right so he's he
just you have to do something but you
can't put him in jail I guess cuz he
hasn't done anything but in the old days
you'd put him into a mental institution
okay this is 100% true it sounds harsh
what Trump is saying what he's saying
here is 100% true eat or evil or Tory is
a is a famous psychologist I've
recommended his books on the program
before he's founder of the treatment
Advocacy Center and his latest book is
American psychosis now the federal
government destroyed the mental illness
treatment system
well back in 2013 he talked about what
it was that the government had done to
destroy the mental health facilities in
the country he talked about how in 1963
John F Kennedy advised addressed
Congress on mental illness and mental
retardation that was the name of the
speech and proposed a new program under
which the federal government would fund
community mental health centers or
CMHC's to take the place of state mental
hospitals the reason was because he had
a younger sister who had a mental
disability and should be put in a state
mental hospital
- freaked him out and so you said the
federal government should take over and
instead they should fund community
mental health centers well over the next
17 years the fens funded nearly 800 of
these with a total of what would be
about 20 billion dollars in today's
dollars and during those same years the
number of patients and state mental
hospitals dropped from 500,000 people to
132 thousand people and the beds were
closed down well it turns out the
community mental health centers right
these these local centers funded by the
feds were not interested actually in
taking care of patients who are being
discharged from the state hospitals
meaning the people who are the most
unsafe instead they're focusing on
people with less severe problems people
who were then termed the worried well so
you know the normal person who's taking
an antidepressant now this is what these
sensors focused on so state mental
institutions which were very bad places
were replaced by something even worse
which was nothing and so a lot of these
people ended up on the streets there was
no way to forcibly to forcibly
involuntarily commit somebody it became
very difficult to actually get somebody
who's dangerous to themself into a
treatment facility right now you have to
provide serious evidence that somebody
is a threat to themselves or others
which means an actual suicide attempt it
means an actual suicide attempt in most
states right you just acting like this
this shooter acted may not be enough in
some of these states so as a fuller Tory
writes he says meantime during the years
the CMHC's were funded Medicaid and
Medicare were created modifications were
made to the Supplemental Security income
and Social Security disability insurance
programs none of these programs was
originally intended to become major
federal support for the mentally ill but
all now fill that role the federal
takeover of the mental illness treatment
system was complete and he concludes
approximately half of the mentally ill
individuals discharged from state mental
hospitals many of whom had family
support saw at outpatient treatment and
have done well the other half many of
whom lacked family support and suffered
from the most severe illnesses such as
schizophrenia and bipolar disorder have
done poorly according to multiple
studies untreated mentally ill are
responsible for 10 percent of all
homicides and a higher percentage of
mass killings constitute 20% of jail and
prison inmates and are at least thirty
percent of the homeless severely
mentally ill and individuals now
inundate hospital emergency rooms
they've colonized libraries parks train
stations and other public spaces this is
not their fault okay and we get
a ton of money on it the total cost on
Mental Illness through all these
supplemental programs is 46 billion
dollars the total cost for mentally ill
individuals through Medicaid and
Medicare is 60 billion dollars that 46
billion dollars is just SSI or SSDI it's
a huge increase in what we are spending
and we are not getting what we paid for
and part of that is because of the
social liberals who decided that it was
important to release people onto the
streets as an element of freedom they
all read One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest
and decided that the entire
institutional system was Nurse Ratched
that wasn't true it was never true okay
so in a second I'm gonna show you some
stuff that Trump said that was not as
great but for that you're gonna have to
go over to Facebook so for now as you're
gonna have to leave Facebook and go and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you get the
rest of the show live you also get to be
part of our mailbag which will be doing
on Friday you have to be part of the
conversation or I'll be taking questions
live from you the audience
the people who subscribe also if you
want to subscribe annually now you get
it for you instead of paying 120 bucks a
year you get a hundred bucks a year it's
$99.99 I believe 99 bucks a year in
order to in order to get the annual
subscription and you get a tumbler the
magical leftist here's hot or cold
tumbler which you get to enjoy every
single day so go and enjoy that with a
subscription or listen later iTunes
SoundCloud please subscribed I Tunes
please lose it leave us review at iTunes
subscribe at YouTube as well we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay now with all of that said with
regard to to what President Trump had to
say that was good President Trump also
had some stuff to say that was not good
and this is where you know President
Trump's an unguided missile President
Trump says a lot of stuff what he
actually implements very rarely ends up
being some of the weird ideas that he
puts it out there yeah I've learned over
the past year that you ought to pay less
attention to what he says he's gonna do
on policy and more attention to what he
actually does on policy but some of the
stuff that he said yesterday about guns
was less than it was less than edifying
so yesterday he was talking about the
deputy who apparently was armed outside
and did not run into harm's way to try
to save the students he said that he
himself from said he himself would have
would have confronted the shooter you
know I really believe you don't know
until you test it but I think I really
believe I'd run in there even if I
didn't have a weapon and I think most of
the people in this room would have done
that too
because I know most of you um no I'm
just gonna put that out there no no no I
don't think most people would run into
the line of fire
unarmed of a guy who had a rifle I think
that's that is really really unlikely I
think the likelihood the president Trump
who does not shall we say have a stellar
record on military matters personally he
you know obviously his bone spurs
prevented him from serving in the
Vietnam War and then he suggested that
his personal Vietnam War was avoiding
STDs during the 1970s I'm gonna go no on
that we can all call him this law
enforcement officer to have done his job
but I think that it's a bit of an
exaggeration to suggest that you
personally are gonna go in there and
save the children by running in there
without a gun that's the whole point you
do need to gun in order to stop a bad
guy with a gun as a general rule and
then Trump followed that up by saying
that he's willing to buck the NRA and
consider some possibilities now is the
smart pasta politics it probably is it's
smart of him he he knows that the NRA
folks are gonna back him no matter what
the NRA has become extraordinarily Pro
Trump in a way that I think is actually
not advantageous to them politically I
think the NRA ought to remain a
bipartisan coalition of gun owners I
think the fact that they've gone so hard
Pro Trump is a mistake at alienates a
lot of people but Trump he's saying
something smart politically but probably
dumb in terms of policy saying that he's
going to buck the NRA and consider some
measures that they may not want
consider about the NRA they're on our
side you guys have four you are so
afraid of the NRA there's nothing to be
afraid of and you know what if then our
with you we have to fight him everyone
Senora that's okay
they're doing what they think is right I
will tell you they are doing what they
think is right but sometimes we're gonna
have to be very tough and we're gonna
have to fight them but we need strong
background checks for a long period of
time people resisted then but now people
I think are really into it and John
Cornyn great guy senator Mitch McConnell
Paul Ryan and Kevin McCarthy hopefully
are gonna work on some legislation I
hope you guys they started already in
fact John has legislation in we're going
to strengthen it we're gonna make it
more pertinent to what we're discussing
but he's already started the process
we've already started so we'll find out
what comes out here but Trump obviously
want to makes it and wants to make some
inroads by by pushing the NRA a little
bit off to the side um do I think that
that's wise you know politically
probably is wise in terms of policy
we'll have to see what actually comes
out now in terms of people who are
hypocrites this is just breaking news
from The Huffington Post is an amazing
thing on the morning after the October
1st mass shooting in Las Vegas a member
of the Democratic Congressional Campaign
Committee is press staff Warren House
candidates and their staffs not to
politicize the shooting that day
politicization according to the DCCC
official included talking about gun
violence prevention policy he says you
and your candidate will be
understandably outraged and upset as
well your community however do not
politicize it today there will be a time
for politics and policy discussion but
any message today should be on offering
thoughts and prayers for victims and
their families and thanking first
responders who saved lives so this of
course would be wise politics but the
Democrats have run screaming from this
the guy who wrote it was Evan Luc ASCII
Luc ASCII is is one of the he's the GCC
regional press secretary I guess and
people are very angry at him in the
Democratic Party for having said this
but look even there's even a bunch of
people who are gun control advocates are
now saying there's not a whole hell of a
lot that we can do in order to stop
these mass shootings and we're not gonna
call for actual bans on semi-automatic
weapons again showing the hypocrisy of
all the folks on the Left who are
virtually signaling speaking of the
virtues signaling there's now going to
call two to boycott FedEx there's been a
call to boycott Amazon
because you can buy NRA products on
Amazon that boycott has been called for
I believe Thursday so that would be a
good time to buy from Amazon folks if
you want to go and buy something now is
the time to buy it on Amazon demonstrate
that you stand with companies that are
not going to close off alternative
political viewpoints out of political
convenience and expediency so check that
out buy something from Amazon now and
Amazon Prime on Thursday I love Amazon
I'd be very upset with them were they to
to try and disassociate politically from
from Second Amendment advocates just
because the media would like them to
okay time for a couple of things that I
like and then some things that I hate so
first a couple of things that I like
yeah I've been writing this book on
philosophy it is not the easiest book to
write because a lot of deep thinking and
that means that I have to listen to deep
music well I well I do this that's how
pretentious I am I'm so pretentious that
when somebody tweeted out today what are
the what album has the three best songs
in a row on it I tweeted out three
separate numbers from bezees Carmen yeah
that's how much of a douche I am in any
case the what I recommend today is a
Brahms string quintet number one which
is just a lovely piece of music I've
gotten very into listening to Brahms
while I work just wonderful stuff here's
Brahms string quintet number one
[Music]
I don't want to do the rest of the show
now I just want to listen to this Brahms
is fantastic a couple of other favorites
that I've been listening to recently
Brahms Piano Quartet number one is
fantastic his his piano trios are all
terrific and really really romantic and
melodic so check those out there they're
really a blast to listen to and they're
very relaxing as well okay other things
that I like so I wanted to play this
yesterday and I did not have a chance it
is the best piece of audio ever so
Michael Wolfe the author of fire in
theory a charlatan a conman
a guy who went into the White House and
basically just wrote down all of Steve
bannon's pathetic musings and then
turned it into a book about how
everybody in the Trump White House was
incompetent and stupid and all the rest
of us
so Michael Wolfe was on Australian Today
Show and he was asked some pretty
specific questions about you say no
reason was the BBC
I'm trying remember where where this was
in any case he was asked specifically it
was it was London's Today Show rather he
was asked specifically about whether he
had any evidence to the effect that
Donald Trump was having an affair which
he had implied he'd suggested that Nikki
Haley was having an affair with Trump
which of course is absolute bunk there's
no evidence to support it whatsoever and
Wolff has been implying it anyway well
Wolff is a specific questions watch as
he pretends he can hear the audio but
notice something weird about this okay
he only says that you can't hear the
audio
every time the person asks him if he can
hear the audio so pretty astonishing
stuff here it is Michael Wolfe doing his
dishonest routine you see during a TV
interview just last month that you are
absolutely sure that Donald Trump is
currently having an affair while
president behind the back of the first
lady and I repeat you said you were yeah
again last week however you backflipped
instead I quote I do not know if the
president is having an affair do you owe
the President and the First Lady an
apology mr. Wolfe I can't hear you hello
last month you said you were absolutely
sure that the president was having an
affair I mean I'm not getting I'm not
getting anything you're not hearing me
mr. Wolfe I'm not getting anything
do you do you hear I'm not I'm not
hearing anything not hearing me
I'm not hearing anything and then he
just gets up and leaves the interviews
he doesn't even wait to see if the if
the audio is gonna come back in because
it didn't go out in the first place so
Michael will remember this was the
person that the media were fawning over
this was the great genius who had
uncovered the truth behind the facade of
the Trump administration oh my goodness
what other stupidity just just grin
watching Michael Wolfe and plod like
that so well done and Michael Wolfe and
we've got to do something about the
spate of earpieces that don't work
apparently
and whether it's Trump with Jake Tapper
or whether it is Michael Wolfe when you
hear a question you don't like suddenly
the earpiece just bugs out very weird
very weird stuff okay time for a couple
of things that I hate okay so thing
number one that I hate there's a the
NCAA has been under severe attack
because the NCAA does have a couple of
stupid rules some of these stupid rules
include that if you are in college and
playing for a college basketball team on
scholarship so let's say that you're
getting a scholarship that's worth 45
grand a year that this somehow
compensates you for the use of your name
and the NCAA can use your name on its
jerseys they can sell those jerseys they
can make millions of dollars off of you
and you have been fairly compensated
with your forty five grand
this is absolutely asinine I've always
thought the NCAA policy here was gross
the same thing is true one and done I
think the one and done rule in college
is ridiculous I think you should be
allowed to go directly in the NBA if you
want to go to the NBA Kobe Bryant did it
LeBron James could do it there been a
bunch of people who tried it and failed
that's okay that's your prerogative
there is no one in zone rule in baseball
by the way you can go directly from high
school to the minor leagues with no stop
in between the one and done rule is
particularly stupid because all of these
kids are going to college four-year are
not suddenly deciding to stick around
and pursue their business economics
degree they're not sticking around
because they really want to go into all
these kids who are going to play at
Kentucky on scholarship they're not
actually going there because they are
deeply invested in getting their
neuroscience degree they're going there
because they know they have to play
there for a year before they can be
drafted by the NBA which is why John
Calipari has been making a pretty solid
living for years and years and years by
simply recruiting four or five guys will
be there for a year renting them for a
year and then sending them on to the NBA
well that policy is really stupid what
that policy is not is racist what that
policy is it's a way for the NBA to
prevent a glut of younger players who
don't know what they're doing and it's a
way for the n-c-double-a to make a lot
of money hey this is greed not racism
it's not the same thing hey well the
Stan Van Gundy though says that
one-and-done is racist again I don't
think it's racist I've said before that
I had that it is weird to me that
somehow baseball has never made this
rule but the NBA has again I don't think
that has to do with race so much as it
has to do with the minor leagues there
there is a minor league that exists in
baseball that does not exist in
basketball right there's a d-league but
that's that's a new creation
essentially the minor leagues our job
and people work in the minor leagues for
10 years nobody's in the d-league for 10
years in any case here's Stan Van Gundy
suggesting that one-and-done itself is a
racist policy the people that were
against them coming out made a lot of
excuses but I think a lot of it was
racist quite honestly and the reason I'm
going to say that is nobody I've never
heard anybody like go up in arms about
oh my god they're letting these kids
come out and go play minor league
baseball or they're letting these kids
come out and go play minor league hockey
they're not making big money in their
white kids primarily and nobody has a
problem but all of a sudden now you've
got a black kid it wants to come out of
high school and make millions that's a
bad decision but by pets in college to
go play for 800 a month in minor-league
baseball
that's a fine decision what the hell was
going on the NCAA is one of the worst
organizations may be the worst
organization in sports and so I agree
with his critique on the n-c-double-a I
don't agree with his critique with
regard to with regard to the race issue
again using race as a proxy for bad
decision-making I think is kind of
stupid and I totally agree with his
entire critique of the n-c-double-a I
think the n-c-double-a is ridiculous I
think that you have to when you see
people selling shoes for a little bit of
extra money and suddenly this is some
sort of terrible thing it's just it's
just stupid all the way through so you
know that that is something I would like
to see and I'd like to see the NCAA
change its policy pretty radically
Eric Dickerson said the same thing he
said this is slavery it's not slavery
it's not remotely resembling slavery
slavery is when people are owned and
then and their labor is owned it is not
when you voluntarily give up your labor
in order so that you can get a college
scholarship and then have a shot at the
NBA so let's not go overboard here okay
so tomorrow we will be broadcasting from
Nebraska where we will be preparing to
speak at Creighton I'm really looking
forward to it and I'm going to do that
that speech I think I've decided I'm
gonna do a full on policy speech about
guns I'm going to explain why what gun
rights are where they come from what
cotton policies work what gun policies
do not we'll take it on from a
statistical level a moral level a
constitutional level so that will be a
full-on examination of the issue I'm
looking forward to giving a creighton
tomorrow night if you're going to bat I
look forward to seeing you there if not
you should be able to watch it online we
will be back here tomorrow with more i'm
ben shapiro this is ben shapiro show
[Applause]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing